my talk today it about making red plus
real and let me begin by saying that
it's it's a challenge to think about red
plus just because of the various levels
of complexity that get involved here
it's it's about looking at aspects of
governance it's about looking at aspects
of ecology about how forest behave about
how the economics behaves about how
local communities think and about how
nations organized and negotiate so it's
all of those things bundled into one and
it's also in a mechanical way it's about
how do you structure a mechanism a
mechanism basically is about who pays
whom how much and for what and how do
you manage that so all of those things
are actually involved in red and I think
that's no surprise that a friend of mine
once described REDD+ and I was talking
to him about it like I am with you he
said my god this must be a true
intelligence test for Humanity firstly
the opportunity I think at a global
scale both the ecological and the
economic dimensions of the opportunity
are easy to to gauge because tropical
forests do store a fourth of all
terrestrial carbon something like 550
gigatonnes out of the 2,000 gigatonnes
that we have tropical forests are also
already a mitigation engine they are
already capturing something like fifteen
percent of our total carbon dioxide
emissions and thirdly of course tropical
forests are considered are described as
a source of emissions of course the fact
is it's our activity is the land-use
change and the degradation that is going
on that is the real source of emissions
but measured in in that way tropical
forests are something like 14 or percent
of the total emissions total man-made
emissions there was a study done a few
years back called the alias review and
they'd made an estimate of the economic
benefits of having the rate of
deforestation out to 2020 and their
estimate was that the present value of
policy actions which led to that having
would be of the order of 4
trillion dollars in present value terms
so ecologically significant economically
sizable I think at a global scale you
can always conveniently make the
argument but the problem is what happens
on a local scale because when we take it
away from the global scale and I'm
skipping past for a reason the national
m and the provision provincial scales
when you bring it to the local scales
what you face is local communities their
forest dwellers their forest dependents
this is their life this is their home
and you're describing and just deciding
about what you want to do with their
lives and homes it's also about looking
at it from perspectives other than
carbon because the forest is not just
sticks of carbon it's about recognizing
that apart from the mitigation of
climate you also have biodiversity
benefits you also have fresh water
benefits you also have community
livelihood benefits which accrue in
terms of non-timber forest products and
in terms of just the sheer being of
these communities in and around forest
areas and I always get a bit irked when
these are described as cool benefits
because the kind of suggests that you're
coming from a carbon perspective and you
call everything else including
livelihoods just a co benefit and the
reality is that that term Co benefit has
come out of the carbon world has come
out of the UNF Triple C so that is not
that's that is the reason why it is is
being used then it's about recognizing
that mitigation is not just about
forests it carbon in forest is part of
an overall terrestrial carbon regime and
very often you have intertwined areas
you have areas where you have forest
farm forest farm next to each other and
you have sometimes the same communities
operating across both forests and farms
so on the one hand if you like to the
left hand side of this dividing line
between the forest and the farm you're
saying I will provide you value for
mitigation in some way and to the right
hand side you saying I will not provide
your value for mitigation whereas their
activities on the farming side the same
communities when we wish to engage as
stakeholders that activities will make a
huge difference the kind of farming that
they engage in does make a difference
towards carbon storage and carbon
sequestration so these are some of the
issues that
you face the moment you bring things
down to the local level and I'm talking
about the big issues I'm not yet going
towards governance and the mechanics of
this whole idea and fundamentally what
we have to recognize when we are looking
at this is that we are dealing with
basically the beginnings of a
terrestrial carbon market place and even
though we came to it from the point of
view of UNF Triple C and a whole host of
negotiations and we came to a trauma
litigation perspective reality is that
in order to move forward in a way that
works and we'd have to think beyond just
forests and beyond just carbon so now we
have broke breaking this out into to
further dimensions it's not only forest
it's about all kinds of landscapes that
are in and around the forest is not only
carbon but it's all of the other
ecosystem services so it's that kind of
three-dimensional framework that you
must you must keep in mind when you
approach redd+ and for those of you who
are involved in projects there's three
groups of you I think these are the
issues that you just need to be
conscious of as you start constructing
your solutions I've called redd+ myself
a clash of Titanic externalities and I
refer to that because basically
ecosystem services to the extent that
they are not market transacted goods and
services are externalities and also the
community aspects of society tend to be
very often ignored I mean we draw a lot
from communities from families from
communities from societies and though
the fabric of the community itself is a
social asset we don't recognize that and
when you come to read plus especially on
the ground that's what it's about
because you're trying to address one
massive externality which is basically
carbon emissions by addressing another
massive externalities which is the role
of the community and the value that it
attaches to where it called home and
where it lives and how it operates
within what is basically its home so
this is what I mean by a clash of
Titanic externalities and of course it
is the ultimate intelligence test for
Humanity if we can crack this I think we
can survive having said all that despite
and despite all that if you think back
to copenhagen which was certainly to me
a huge stressful time both personally as
well as professionally
it's the one thing REDD+ was the one
thing that actually survived that in
time s of course we came out with a kind
of basic plus us a memorandum out of
Copenhagen which kind of drifted its its
way forward kind of and then we came out
with red plus actually being
strengthened in fact it was reduced in
in length from a seven page to a four
pager but it was in fact strengthened in
the process of being reduced and it was
agreed upon remarkably by all of the
nations all of the same nations who just
refused to sign on the dotted line for
anything on the mainstream in other
words the annex one stream in this side
alley called the in the ad hoc working
group for long-term cooperative action I
mean just by the time you finish that
just think about the words ad hoc a doc
means just ad hoc right it's not very
important working group means it's just
a working group is not the mainstream
for long-term cooperation I mean anyone
is if pigs can fly long-term cooperation
things are like that so it's quite an
amazing thing that something classified
in such a such a way it could actually
survive but it did and a second
interesting feature of this is that
around that time a bit after a bit
before in a bit after that time there
was a report published called the global
redesign initiative now only a group of
people who are corporate CEOs could be
so proud as to think that they can
design something globally but they did
sure enough this was the World Economic
Forum so we had the global redesign
initiative published and they identified
to praise them I think they identified
the cause of the problem actually while
it was still happening and they
identified that as the the lack of
sufficient focus on prongs what they
said was that you need in order to have
anything that is truly global in context
it has to work both at the UN or the
multinational level it has to work also
at the set of what they call prong two
which is groups of countries with a
commonality of interest and vision in
moving forward something both in this
case from the buy side and the sell side
and thirdly it's got to work on the
basis of the private sector so prong one
the UN trong or national prong prong two
groups of nations and prong three
corporates and interestingly enough II
even though the annex 1 negotiations in
my opinion and I agree with this this
global redesign initiative report fail
because there wasn't sufficient
addressing of prongs to and prams 3 in
the case of redd+ and in the case of
forest carbon there was always a focus
on prong two because the whole idea had
been conceived a few sessions ago with
P&G and a few other countries feeling
that it was possible to create a forest
carbon initiative for mitigation and it
was just a small group it was
essentially countries which then finally
met again in Bali in 2010 in February
and at that time there were just 13
countries i was there in the room there
were just 13 countries in that room it
included the big big boys if you like
brazil was there india was there china
was represented no way germany these
were all there but can you imagine there
was a tiny group of countries and of
course PNG was there who were the
intellectual ID ators if you like of the
idea to begin with and that group of 13
then gradually became 26 27 countries by
the time they met again in in oslo and
then they met again in paris and then by
that time it had grown to 50 plus
countries but it was actually a prong to
kind of initiative it came from a small
group which then grew bigger and bigger
in terms of the actual commitments now
of course this prong true was reflected
in the if you like negotiations speak
the UNF Triple C even after [ __ ] ad-hoc
working group for long term cooperative
actions but the actual decisions on we
are going to pay you are going to
receive here's let's decide sit down and
decide how much we pay and how much you
receive and why and wherefore that was a
prong too it was a group of countries
and out of that negotiation itself came
commitments of the order of three and a
half billion dollars overall and that
includes of course the
half-million-dollar commitment by
Germany which runs out in 2012 Germany
now remains committed to another
half-billion dollars per annum that's
Angela Merkel's commitment and it's been
ratified by by their by their by their
Parliament no way has of course already
committed a billion each and that's
being being worked on right now to
Brazil and to Indonesia so the hell of a
lot came out of this prong to
so despite it being challenging in the
most complex ways and despite it being
you know difficult because of what it's
trying to address is two massive
externalities trying to be resolved at
the same time it seems to be moving
forward now typically what you will see
with with red plus is a kind of concept
of a business as usual here I've drawn a
diagram to explain what I mean by this
basically the light blue line represents
palvin stocks and you can see that by
the decline it is a kind of gradual
deforestation scenario the vertical
black line is now it's when we are
beginning the crediting period as it's
called and typically you'll have someone
preparing a model for a business as
usual a kind of forecast of business as
usual but the reference level in other
words the so-called baseline as they
call it does not have to be the business
as usual it is it could be lower it
could be higher and there are different
implications on whether it's lower or
higher higher means it's more
challenging lower you might argue that
the buyers are more unwilling to pay
that much but at the same time they
might be more waiting because at the
initial stages it kick-starts the whole
program and then of course there's the
actual level that goes along and now
there's also the current level so you
might if you want to be aggressive and
if it's an area which is small
provincial area which is open and can
only go up because you are reforesting
it you might argue why do you need a
baseline because everything's gone so
you should start at zero and whatever is
going up there should be a minimum
natural accretion and then kind of a
good behavior additional on top of that
so you could argue that the current
level could also be a baseline or a
reference level but just look at the
differences because the actual level
versus the the reference level could be
potentially negative which means no
reward it could be small positive it
could be big positive it could be huge
positive and they're literally the study
was done with sure that they're almost
two orders of magnitude depending on how
you set baselines based on some actual
examples that was studied so the reward
and the performance actually depends a
lot on these baselines
now one of the things that you would
have noticed that in talking baselines I
I haven't actually said at what scale
right is this at a national scale is it
at a prevention scale or is it at a
project scale and that's deliberate
because the real answer is it could be
hit any of those scales and I will come
back to that when we talk about
mechanism structuring the complexities
with red plus begin almost the moment
you start defining what you mean so
thankfully deforestation actually at
least has a commonly accepted definition
which is in UF UNF Triple C decisions in
other words under ninety two nations
that actually agreed how to define
deforestation you might laugh but
actually that's quite an achievement I
mean if you put 192 people there's only
about 24 of you or their bounds if you
put 192 of you in a large room bowers
auditorium and said okay guys we all
want to decide which movie we are going
to watch tonight and everyone has an
equal voice and an equal opinion and any
one of you disagreeing on which movie
are going to watch tonight can end the
entire discussion what what bets would
you place that you would agree on a one
movie to watch tonight right so the
thing is you're trying to get people to
agree on something quite significant
like climate emissions which have costs
and benefits and relative costs and
benefits so it's not a and each sentence
each word in each sentence has to be
negotiated so it's a non-trivial
achievement that at least we have one
definition of deforestation now the
degradation is a little bit more
complicated because here we are talking
about a reducing stock in forest a
reducing density and it could be
degradation of different kinds i'm
talking carbon right now but if its
degradation can also refer to other
services as an other ecosystem services
being degraded even though the carbon
element may be the same so the way the
kyoto protocol defines degradation and
this is based on the IPCC's
recommendation is a direct human induced
long-term loss persisting four xes or
more of it or at least y % of forest
carbon stocks since time T and not
qualifying as deforestation and would
you believe this definite
with so many variables three variables
in it only becomes actionable when all
of those three variables are defined by
agreement so all that's been agreed is
actually a framework of a definition of
degradation which then has to come into
practice based on assigning values to
those variables it's complication one
even by the definition it is difficult
but going back to my previous diagram
notice what I've hinted here is what is
it about this diagram is basically
stocks and that's the direction to start
thinking about this if you measure
stocks at time zero vs stocks at time
one time to time end whatever it is then
at least you know that doesn't matter
whether that loss in stock or increase
in stock has happened because of
deforestation which could be land use
area based or degradation which could be
thinning out but there is a loss of
stock then the challenges let's measure
the stock at these different times and
how do we do that so here's how the
whole process is is approached within a
UNF Triple C context and the inputs of
the IPCC are quite critical because
there is a lot written on this for many
many years the approach is basically
estimate the actual emissions from a
reference level which which I drew
diagrammatically and do that by making
use of the IPCC's tears and tier 1 2 3
are basically different levels of direct
measurement in other words tier 1 is
where you don't know much about the
location you are using standardized
factors based on the type of biome and
the type of densities that you get in
these various biomes and you're using
basically default values if you like
just think computer program with default
parameters you are doing that
essentially tr2 is where you have some
idea of the location but you're going
about still using estimates and theater
3 is actual direct measurement of stocks
and density now there are two aspects to
this the way that is measured is you
measure the area which is under land use
and it could be different kinds of land
use it could be dense forest it could be
degraded for us and it could be other
kinds such as wetlands and agricultural
lands and so on and you measure changes
in land
and then you measure what our standard
stock densities in these different kinds
of land use it could be standard if
you're going at a Tier one as in you
know the default value approach or it
could be actual measurements right down
onto the ground if you're going all the
way to tier three so they're different
levels of effort required in measuring
these but they are all valid by the way
so you can have an agreement based on
tier 1 numbers you can have an agreement
based on tier 2 and tier 3 and when you
think in terms of the two dimensions
here in other words the changes in land
use and the respective measures of
stocks in the different kinds of land
use then you'll immediately think of the
kind of errors that you can introduce
right so you're doing this on a
satellite basis maybe the technology is
not good enough maybe there are errors
in the technology maybe the
interpretation of the land use is is
different I'll give us more example do
you know typically to what area most
most satellites can measure forests and
plantations and stuff like that anyone
has an idea as to what is your your area
the minimum area down to which most
satellite systems can measure yeah
exercises is how many how many square
meters sorry yeah the in fact goes down
even to five by five goes on five by
five but typically people don't
necessarily go to five by five because
of the cost and density of that data
they will go to hire 10 by 10 20 by 20
25 by 25 and so on and and you will see
situations where grid lines at grid
sizes have been chosen where it's
actually difficult to differentiate
between a plantation and a forest where
you have if you have a plantation which
is a dense plantation differentiating
that between a plantation the forest
becomes tough and in those pixel sizes
so there are there are complications
here in terms of the technology and then
there are differences due to
interpretation and sometimes different
different sets of measurements could be
made using different levels of detail of
pixel size
so that's just in terms of the land use
and then of course there's a whole issue
of stocks so do do you correctly
estimate stocks based on IPCC tr1
estimates generally not because their
estimates do you correctly estimate them
even with tier 2 and 3 sometimes and
sometimes not there are unrecognized
gradations if you like I'm you know all
this so you can actually go wrong in
putting stock estimates and then
remember you're always comparing one set
of stocks with the other it's always
this kind of biome versus that kind of
bio and land-use change from one to the
other the technology of remote sensing
has to be supplemented typically with
some kind of measurements on the ground
so brown shoe thing has has to be
applied as well you can't only do this
on a pure satellite-based measurements
and finally even after you've done all
that you still need to have some degree
of verification of monitoring that's
going on of of reporting of this n-no
verification and it's got to be done in
a way that neither disenfranchises or
alienates locals because then your
scheme will not succeed you may have
perfect measurements and you will have
all kinds of mismanagement going on on
the ground neither does it have to be at
the expense of losing independence
because you do have to have some degree
of independent measurements so really
have to take both those factors into
account now going back to this I
mentioned that this whole basic concept
of the baseline and the reference level
and the fact that there is a business as
usual and you can do this out of
different levels here are a few bullet
points which are important in terms of
doing a red plus team purely at a
national level in other words countries
agree with each other to reward or
receive reward based on how they've
performed and then i will look at the
same context right down to the other
extreme at the project level how does
that work so let's look at the national
crediting approach well first good news
is that there is money right clearly
there's collectively seven billion
dollars now which is available for this
on the other hand there is no clarity as
yet as to how
that pie is to be split then we have the
issues of country risk and regulatory
risk country risk means that fine you've
agreed but what if payments are a
challenge I mean in the old days it was
possible to say that developed countries
will pay well there are certain European
countries which are quote unquote
developed which are in no position to
pay so the question is there is country
risk and it's real and the other side is
of course regulatory risk which is what
if there are changes in regulations what
if negotiations result in a change in
regulations and what if based on those
new regulations you have different
answers so you have to factor these
risks into account very much even at the
country scale a third issue that we have
to address is basically to do with
what's called nesting which is that if
you have decided to reward or not reward
on a national level how does that
translate to the province level or the
state level and finally how did the does
that translate to the project level
because if a nation is building up a
national biodiversity strategy and
action plan or is building up a forestry
plan it will have to provide incentives
to the ground to be able to get
afforestation happening happening or to
get reductions in deforestation in other
words it will have to pass incentives
down in some way or the other but
without without specifying how it gets
quite challenging so you might find that
if it's passed on incentives or if it's
created some degree of action on the
ground how do you ensure that that
action is rewarded in years in which the
country receives no reward because if
there is no funding at the country level
it is a challenge how will you actually
reward things further down the ground
and then finally because I'm this really
related to this is that unless you have
some form of price discovery taking
place some form of market action taking
place some form of engagement of private
actors how would you actually
incentivize odeon or disincentivize them
what they are making trade-offs they are
making choices there is a choice to
DeForest it has certain economic values
what's the alternative in what way are
you framing that alternative what's the
price at which they will stop
deforesting and and do something else as
in abstain from deforesting and further
what's the other price at which
would actually start engaging in a
foresting and remember when we get down
to the community level it's the same
people is the same communities the same
private landholders it's the same groups
on the ground who are involved here and
if we look at the project level these
other two issues are addressed certainly
the inclusion issue is addressed because
you will include municipalities
cooperatives forest concessionaire ease
private landholders local community
landowners that that's fine you've
covered that because you are taking it
down to the project level you're
providing rewarded the project level and
you're also creating a price signal
because you're setting the price at a
level which you believe as a counterpart
is going to incentivize them to change
behavior as in deforestation stop or
indeed afforestation start so that bit
is taken care of but now you've created
another problem which is how do you
ensure that by incentivizing behavior
and creating market signals you're
actually achieving what you wanted in
the first place sure you've incentivize
the community and possibly even the
province but how do you ensure that in
the case of a community all of them
within a province are doing the same
thing in other words there is no leakage
as in yes I'm looking after my area
because i'm getting my red + return and
i'm going to my neighborhoods plot
neighborhood 4s and picking up wood from
there or deforesting that and feeding
the lumber markets how do you prevent
that and even if you sure that at is
province level how do you prevent how do
you assure that at the country level in
a country large countries like India
Brazil etc where they are 27 30 States
so these are these are still issues and
then the question is if you can't ensure
that then if you can't ensure
additionality as its as its called
because of this leakage taking place
then why should the credits that you've
generated from this be marketable at an
international level why would any
country in the right minds want to buy
this because net net you've not achieved
anything potentially so these are the
issues here so typically what tends to
be thought about and that's something
that is there in the reading that I've
prescribed you which is aryl dangle sins
paper we tend to think in terms of a
composite we tend to think in terms of a
scheme where not only is the community
engaged but also the state and province
and also the nation so there's some
degree of sharing of the benefits that
takes place along these three tiers that
creates the incentive
for relationality to be achieved and
that has to be achieved through
something called nesting which I'll come
to in a minute but firstly before I go
to that let's let's figure out what
exactly are we talking about what is
being traded for its carbon nice to say
that but just think of what all forest
carbon consists of it's the trees and
forests on above the ground it's the
root matter underneath the ground the
living above-ground biomass and
below-ground biomass it's the dead
organic matter that's basically wood
fallen logs and so on and so forth it's
dead organic matter such as leaves and
litter and so on then there's organic
matter in the soil which is being added
to do 2d composting and so on has been
added to over time and then finally
there's even harvested wood products
because if it's a plantation or if it's
a forest which is open to sustainable
management of forests then you are
creating presumably log cabins or
presumably furniture which is presumably
not being burnt every day so it's
actually there it's actually achieved
some reasonable purpose in terms of
sequestering carbon so when we are
talking about what we are trading that's
actually a very important and central
question any marketplace the first thing
you decided what's the quality and this
commodity is a very complicated in fact
it's hardly a commodity as you can see
its components are so many typically
what is being discussed these days is
that you need to clearly state which one
you're talking about and typically it's
the two that I've highlighted that is
the living above-ground biomass and the
living below-ground biomass that tend to
be looked at as the key elements of
forest carbon and once again depending
on who is measuring I've seen in
Australia for instance and New Zealand
there are measures which go down all the
way across so they're measuring all
aspects of forest carbon but not every
scheme in not every country has actually
got a focus on all the aspects of forest
carbon and you just have to recognize
that whatever you are creating by way of
a mechanism is clearly defined and
states what it's measuring the second
aspect apart from defining your
what you are trading is to define the
mechanism because a trade in other words
a promise to deliver something as in
reduced deforestation and a promise in
return for money it's just a promise how
do you ensure that it's actually
delivered because the promised it refers
to a future date someone will have to
measure someone will have to clear and
settle this and that's what clearing and
settlement is is basically about and
typically this happens at what is called
a settlement date which could be some
future date and I'm using the example
here which which is from the Munden
project which is quite nicely framed
which uses corn and the other side of it
is money or what exactly is corn and
what happens if you fail to deliver on
that contract well firstly anyone want
to suggest what exactly is corn has
anyone seen how many varieties of corn
does anyone know how many varieties of
Conda and Peru for example how many
species of corn are in Peru any guesses
23 higher close it's 52 different
species of calling so try defining a
commodity when you say corn sounds easy
right corn corn is corn right but no
it's not as easy as that so it takes an
effort so this is how the cbot actually
defines the corn contract so basically
says corn is not any corn it's yellow
corn and yellow corn is either yellow
which is kind of obvious or it could be
reddish but you know we call it yellow
because it looks yellowish so it goes to
that and then it talks about the various
qualities of corn and this is all to
define the contract so there are three
kinds of qualities right we're basically
if the corn has a minimum weight per
bushel of 56 grams or whatever it is I
think's grams and if its maximum heat
damage is less than a tenth of a percent
and if its maximum total damage kernels
in in that bushel is less than three
percent and if the maximum broken and
foreign material mixed in is less than
two percent then that's the highest
quality if it doesn't meet any of those
criteria but meets the next rung of
criteria then it becomes the next
quality and then
the third quality and so on so they
actually three qualities and there's a
standard premium and discount the
contract is for the middle quantity and
there's a standard premium and discount
for grade 1 and grade 3 so corn is easy
right corn is gone this is how the
contract is defined so it's really
important to fix what is it that you're
trading but relative to forest con is
easy can you imagine trying to fix
forest biomass and that's the complexity
here so fixing the contract for forest
biomass is a non trivial exercise and
this is something that all of you will
those of you are involved in the red
plus projects when you're looking at the
carbon side of the contracts that you
are designing and then going beyond that
and looking at the biodiversity side in
in three cases in all three cases and in
one case which is yes only looking also
at fresh water and community benefit
sides just think this through you have
two very clear and precise as to how you
define your contracts now some of the
parameters that are official parameters
by the way and you don't have to stop
here so some of the parameters that you
will have to decide when you're
designing your carbon contract in your
specific REDD+ scheme are these three
parameters you'll have to decide what's
the minimum forest area we talked about
pixel size representing five by five
meters or 25 by 25 meters and so on well
you'd have to decide like what's your
pixel size so to speak and what's been
agreed within the UNF triple sec context
once again is a massive range it's point
zero five to one hectares so point just
to give you an idea one hectare is a lot
of area you can kind of argue it's a
small forest but it's it's a decent
holding point zero five hectares is one
twentieth of Hector that's 10,000 anyone
know how much is that when ten thousand
square meters / 20 so that's 500 square
meters that's about 20 20 x 25 meters
that's about 20 meters that's about 25
meters so technically as per the UNF
Triple C an area of trees yeah forest
the size of Bauer auditorium would
classify as before
so this is the flexibility that is there
officially in these God in defining what
is forest right imagine how would you
like to own a forest which is the size
of the bower auditorium this is about 20
meters by 25 meters gives you an idea
now secondly what about the the height
that matters as well so once again the
minimum height is what they are setting
as to what qualifies as far as is
between two and five meters how high is
two meters is about human height anyone
been to South Africa to the phain boss
so fine boss is basically a very thin
open kind of shrubland I would call it
really and there are trees there which
are fully grown trees which are this
high so you have to be careful what you
are calling two meters is yeah two
meters is nothing if you've gone to the
Yale forest but two meters in the Fane
Buster in in South Africa is actually
quite quite a tall tree and a really
tall tree and Excel giant would be like
three meters high you know it looked
like this and that's a big tree so this
this sort of diversity is real and you
have to recognize where you are when you
set these parameters and finally the
crown cover basically the the amount of
if you like area that from a satellite
would appear to be covered they define
is between 10 and 30 percent now
obviously if you're talking about
Indonesia as some of you are in in
Sumatra kalimantan and the third group
of you is talking about yeah Sunni I
don't know how much canopy cover out
there is but I'd be astonished it which
was less than seventy percent so these
are kind of theoretical but just be
aware that this is what this is what
we're talking about but that's minimum
free cover so you can you can define
your your contracts accordingly and when
it comes to measurement and I mentioned
that there are these three sets of tears
that the ipcc's guidance provides the
IPCC had written this up in the days
when it was called Lulu CF land use land
use change and forestry and these three
tiers are actually quite complicated so
this is what the actual project report
says I'll just read it you can read it
for yourself that we found that the
process of explaining the IPC is IPCC's
methods to
market participants to be a very
difficult task an examination showed
that they were almost impossible to
summarize in a comprehensive way that
would be acceptable to financial market
participants largely due to the length
and scientific content so please let's
not do that if you want your schemes to
work be it in kalimantan or or sumatra
or yes Unni don't fall into the trap of
just going to that length and detail of
scientific think of some simple way of
framing your contracts okay now let me
come and I'll try and be be relatively
expeditious in this because I have a
sharp deadline I have to leave at five
but I'll try and cover some of the key
challenges of red class now so the first
challenge of redd+ is basically how do
you slice the pie and this is there is
money available who gets what why and
wherefore I could just sort of I could
have sliced tension in the air in the
room in Bali we're back in febri 2010
because we had Brazil and Indonesia and
everyone in their very polite way was
asking the same question so how do you
decide who gets what and it was
different official ways of framing
exactly the same question it was framed
in about ten different ways over the two
and a half hours that we discussed this
matter it was an important question to
answer the second issue is how do you
integrate the many trunk but i'll call
trong two initiatives after the World
Economic Forum's terminology we have the
UN Read program I from memory it's about
100 140 or million dollars worth of
financing we have the World Bank's
forest carbon partnership facility
another 45 50 million dollars then we
have the interim redd+ partnership it
was created in Bali in 2010 februari and
has been since grown in strength and
become kind of the mainstream and it's
not that I want to argue against the
philosophy of let two thousand flowers
bloom but the fact is there are three
different institutional frameworks out
here working towards the same end and it
can only be a recipe for confusion at
least and potential conflict if they
don't work at least very closely in
collaboration with each other and to
this day I think there's still not a
sense of close collaboration I think
there's a
of sharing of information which is good
but I wouldn't call it a close
collaboration and yet this has to be a
network this has to be one network that
works together on on this issue of redd+
pools information pools ideas pools
knowledge pools capacities and I think
that really is key it's not yet happened
in in a meaningful way thirdly there's
the challenge of capacity building
because no matter who you read and which
recommendation you read on the subject
of redd+ all of them will begin with
there is a need for capacity building
you need to be able to have established
legal capacity institutional capacity
the capacity to measure technology all
of that stuff and of course set up mrv
and with if you go ahead and build a red
Christine without those capacities then
you will effectively end up with an
implementation challenge because the
contracts that you write may not be
legal as in they may not be legal
contracts and if they are legal or
defined legal they may not be
enforceable and you will have performs
performance risks of a fundamental kind
this is essentially unenforceable
contracts so we don't want to have that
situation and finally there's also
capacity of originations it's not easy
to find good projects and finding them
and then ensuring that there are people
looking after them and managing them
that's that's a challenge and last but
not the least is political capacity as
in how do you ensure that people
actually believe this is a good thing to
do how do you ensure that local
communities vote for the politicians who
have gone in favor of saying we want
that plus and not the other way around
and finally I think which is the the the
heart of the problem is how do you
structure the mechanism for redd+ to me
mechanism structuring for redd+ is the
real nub of the challenge because what
we've got so far is a broad framework
approved by the UN after [ __ ] agreed
definitions of what is deforestation and
so on and an agreed direction in which
to go including involving the local
communities and all that has been agreed
that is great but what hasn't been
agreed as yet and the work that hasn't
yet begun is basically structuring a
mechanism and that's what needs to be
done
so here are the aspects of that which
which I'll go through in in in the next
few minutes firstly we got to recognize
what place this red plus scheme has is
it part of Kyoto in other words is it
going to be part of the scheme that is
Kyoto successor where some countries are
paying some are receiving and this is
just an element of that compliance that
is being achieved on the side of those
who are paying or receiving or is it
something extra in other words if
targets have been set at the national
level are red plus targets in other
words green carbon talk is going to be
part of those or are they additional to
those that's the first decision that has
to be made and that's a global scale
decision the second is how do you
involve countries in a meaningful way on
both the buy side and the sell side
there are 25 27 odd countries which have
tropical forests which are interested in
involving themselves in a tropical
forest carbon market place and there are
just a handful literally who are already
committed as invisibly committed no
matter whether an X 1 works doesn't work
no matter whether a WGAL TCA works or
not they committed they want to do this
they want to move forward Norway Germany
UK etc but how do you make this work for
192 countries that's a non-trivial
non-trivial ask remember also that when
you say the buy side and by side I mean
those who are it's not both are buying
and selling something the people the
countries on the buy side are basically
buying reduced risk in carbon emissions
in other words an improvement if you
follow Stern an improvement in their
potential productivity and their
potential GDP and the reduced risk of
their gdp in the future so they are
buying something as well they are
selling something as well and they are
providing the money because they're
getting something in return which is
better mitigation through forest carbon
reductions on the sell side are
countries where they are reducing their
use of the forest and reducing their
consumptive use of the forest or the
destruction of forests assets and at the
same time they are selling that
reduction and at the same time they're
getting cash for it
so both sides are providing something it
is a deal it's not as it I don't like
the use of the word donor countries
because it's not a donation they are
doing this in a broader wider
self-interest because they are eighty
percent of the global economy and
hopefully they would like to remain
there and they won't if the economy
itself suffers there are issues in terms
of recognizing who all is involved on
the sell side it's got to be
comprehensive as I mentioned neither
situation either national or only
project works really and finally you
have to recognize the rights of forest
dwellers and for us dependence and you
have to address a whole host of water
actually politically quite difficult and
also administrative administratively
quite complex challenges and I'm going
to make a list of these and spend a few
moments going through each of these so
these are the key challenges for
structuring REDD+ mechanism number one
agree the regime in the frame book and
that's something that's kind of
background but it's got to be clear as
to in what context are you doing this is
it additive or is it part of the
framework overall off of Kyoto to you
have to ensure that the financing is
sustainable because wise I say that
today we have seven billion dollars
that's one off and that's coming from
the coffers of governments and frankly
straining the fiscal deficits of of a
few willing G g20 government g7
governments in this case moving forward
is not a sustainable strategy because
how many times can you repeat this it's
going to be difficult in a marketplace
which is sized at anything between 20
and 50 billion dollars 30 billion
dollars is the number that most people
McKinsey and others tend to use as the
size of the marketplace how many times
are you going to be able to tap willing
donors at the national level this thing
has to become a market mechanism you
have to have rules which obliged
corporations to commit finances towards
this mechanism in other words the
so-called by side has to telescope down
to business sectors much in the same way
as the European Union ETS does the EU
ETS basically is a collection of 2500
come
obliged by their national governments to
meet certain commitments on emissions
and in turn in turn in in order to meet
those emissions they do get certain
breaks on the other side so it's not a
it's not a zero-sum game but they said
it's not just a one-sided situation
either thirdly you have to look at the
other ecosystem services because it is
the case and many earlier lecturers have
talked about different dimensions of
this of having a situation where you
focus on rewarding one particular
ecosystem service you end up depleting
the other and the same here in forest
carbon there is a syndrome called the
so-called empty for a syndrome where if
you only provide a forest community
incentives for carbon and they
understand the means of measurement you
are potentially incentivizing them to
deplete biodiversity to effectively rob
the forest of everything other than what
is high carbon content and they know
because at least this is being rewarded
and the rest isn't so you you do have an
issue there in terms of how you spread
the benefits and what you call cool
benefits in the words of the carbon
community or what we call ecosystem
services finally agreeing the tiers of
beneficiaries we saw the problems we're
trying to do this at the national scale
we saw also the problem of additionality
of doing this only at the project scale
the fact is that local governments as in
state governments provincial governments
do have a role to play they are
important they are the people who will
finally organize things within a legal
framework that works and you have to
recognize them and eligibility has to be
established both on the buy side and the
sell side so on the sell side
eligibility would be well do you have a
local community or a local stakeholder
who is committed to that particular area
where a project is taking place do you
have established rules and regulations
within the country and the state which
ensure that some form of reward can be
legally administered and legally
enforced and on on the buy side as well
do you have a situation where either the
government commits or has a national
legislation where there is a commitment
over a long term to continue this in
other words there's not an exposure to
the risk of country risk or of
regulatory risk rules changing halfway
between your your scheme funding can be
provided in one of many ways today what
we have is a very rudimentary fund phase
as asked all basically a few governments
have decided to pull money together not
physically pull it together but there's
a group of them and they provided X and
this can be concrete eyes in the form of
an actual fund a proper fund which
collects money from donor governments
and allocates it on some basis across to
the recipients now once again when i say
donor i don't mean they're donating but
that's the term that is being used but
basically is it's the buy side pulling
together funds for the sell side but the
fact is once again this fund phase is
really only in the intermediate phase
once you've established capacity in
country and once you've established
rules and regulations and once you've
established the nature of the contract
and you move forward with that the fun
phase will only take it thus far it has
to graduate from there to being some
kind of a market phase and that requires
rules and regulations being imposed on
the buy side which means companies much
in the same way as the EU ETS today for
in the European Union are committed to
reduce emissions below certain levels
and they can trade their emissions so
also here sorry actually it's a good
point because let's do one next one day
how does this get started so we have to
structure it in a way that enables what
we call nesting now Lessing is typically
talked of in terms of just nesting in
terms of have some means of defending
the local performer if the state doesn't
perform and defend the state performer
if the nation doesn't perform so that is
typically what next thing is required
whoever is successful at their level
should be rewarded when they succeed and
should not be subject to a higher troupe
performing but to do that resting you
need financing because when you say
reward you need a sum if you are playing
something has to take out of fun that
fun in a situation where you have
national state and local companies has
to be invested funding settlers actually
three levels of funds that were
available funding the state level of
projects are funded the national level
of states and if you're working in terms
of a global corporate you'll actually
have a fun which is the basic
fundamental a caulking gun which
actually works at a country them so you
have to look at all of these aspects as
actually formed enhancing and of support
for financing at the CDM doesn't need to
work better a sequel in Syria you've
already got a European Union ETS scheme
which says you have certain caps and not
meet the caps divider both buy and sell
complex amongst each other or media
relations that you can't either buy and
sell contracts or meteor missions then
you go out there to the developing world
and by CDM as per the following 70-odd
different kinds of contracts so they are
allowing offsets and offsets are a point
of challenge when it comes
+ n my argument and the reason the daily
challenges largely on moral national
grants because there are countries
Bolivia Venezuela few others were saved
well firstly they don't like it plus the
challenge that class and it was actually
an executive action by the person in
charge of this disagreement could
finally put the gravel down she said I
still remember that you know we heard
Bolivia we have consensus consensus is
not you know militants those were her
words when she said that and she quote
the gavel down and that enabled this
whole meaning to go forward but
basically there are challenges at
another stranger many countries who
don't like the idea of profits because
there is an issue in terms with an
offset you are enabling the fundamental
activity that should have been
controlled to not be controlled instead
you are basically squeezing the sausage
the need is going to some other side
what's the point but the point is that
this sausage if you want to think of
emissions still already does add
something like thirty percent coming
from the rest of the top three so the
fact is the sausage already does include
a fair amount of green carbon emissions
and it is okay to focus on the sixteen
sixty or seventy percent which are brown
a burn on energy and and and industry
missions but you can't only focus that
because you want the team by ignoring
the thirty percent
non-industry anonymity so you need to
have some concept that there must be
some level of offset would be ten
percent be a 20-percent be 30 percent
which is technically acceptable and if
you accept some offset that's when a
scheme like this like Red Cross tango
because then you can follow the same
framework and Errol angles on and the
curators also believe the same you can
follow the same kind of framework as
easily followed within CDN because then
you suddenly committed options where I
differ from them is the fact that I feel
today's CDM is part of a bigger problem
which is that the EU ets has got limits
which are too loosely are too too
lenient basically the caps in the or
convenient can be
you know they're the first ones to have
Taksim but they set them at too lenient
11 on the net result is that we have
over supplied in fact I feel that the
challenges is not we not very sure let
me come too late then you come to
flooding and so on the challenge is not
about plugging the time is the other way
around sorry I need to finish so we have
this condition task now what do I mean
by open architecture the whole idea is
that if you have a fun face and it's
moving at some point into a place where
there's no compares the negotiation for
contracts you need to have some
transparency and availability of
information for prices deputizing where
the last person comes back and I've
talked about nesting and I just want to
close the discussion next few minutes
we're talking about what i call the
Porsche main are there are four issues
which tend to get presented at issues
and they tend to absorb a lot of energy
but actually they're not here this is a
minor so first we punch ability there's
always the argument that green happen is
not fungible with graham Cavanaugh it
with normal heart and funny as far as
I'm concerned for the last thirty 30
years we've had two major oil Model T's
North Sea oil that's bred in brentwood
trading at the same time as as wti west
texas intermediate they are both lights
we loot they've always hated with a
spread between them and they are both
benchmarks not one energy trader or oil
trader whose pain in my team or other
ever complained oh my god there's no
funds ability these contracts are not
fungible their true forms of oil they're
both I people just get used to it
likewise with carbon they will be more
than one kind of car let's get useful
stop complaining about like a hundred so
that's that's my point and by the way
brent was the W has been having every
now n blows out of work portions because
there's some kind of ground-based
problem in Texas which is where most of
it today from and the net result is
working on there is a blow out of the
spread but it's usually one or two dot
and it comes back on that's fair trade
that's it happens secondly offsets I've
talked about the importance of objects
we mean to it there are issues still
with some countries are options but I
think they need to be set aside some
level of upset is appropriate can't be
zero percentage because that defeats the
whole funding possibility of wit class
and I agree their accounting hundred
percent as was argued by some companies
way back then in the original Rio
meeting because that's taking it to the
other extreme the issue of flooding is
largely a Chanel because the fear was in
the urban condition at that time and
that's why there is still no linking
directed between CDM and and
deforestation and
yes is the fear was that's how that'd be
so much emission emission reduction
contracts from forestry that they would
flood the market place in the classroom
the price has gone but the reason for
that is not confronted by a great
problem but because he is doing it
because there's too much supply and to
living our lives a problem of inflation
and finally there is this feeling that
some big race lines must get negotiated
in that typical closed room situation of
192 country resin there must be a set of
negotiated baselines and this I think
contains judge the answer to your
question which is that I do not agree
that there should be a negotiation in
fact I think that if you go Clark and
negotiated baseline you will be forever
trying to agree what I think should be
done is that you should create an open
architecture structure where basically
bilateral negotiations are possible
between and Germany in a Norway under
one name and a state India or the state
and visit on the other part of an
overall ledger which is recording every
ticket every day that is being done is
being clearly recorded and transmitted
recorded with a price with a measurement
baseline so that the underlying contract
that has been transacted has been
clearly recorded right down to the
detail but made transparent when you
have that database gradually growing
basically the price discovery mechanism
and yes there will be many colors of
winter that in many shades because no
one forest is the same as you have a no
political context for same as the other
that's the complexity I think that has
to be addressed and this is where those
agreements that you mentioned in terms
of having a national framework and have
any international agreement that's the
nature of that agreement you have to
agree how rather than a green what if
you start dictating what as in a
standard contract across literally
dozens of different by on Tyson and
dozens of different social cultural and
political context I think we will fail I
think we can succeed if we recognize
also then there are other dimensions to
this because agreeing the power inside
is just step one the fact is that there
are other things that you have to look
at and I will now come to be very
quickly in a few minutes come to the two
projects that are addressing
biodiversity if you like the additional
ecosystem service and the one project
that's addressing a whole host of other
things which is basically a landscape a
squared plus on yes women now you can
have a situation where a red class
biodiversity premium is applied over and
above the value of cup and it can once
again be constructed based on an
existing setup which is working at the
project level the state level
and the Nationals and you need to have a
register at the at the national level
you need to have details recorded
literally down to the contract length
and you need to have that transparency
otherwise the next contract does not
know where to benchmark I said there has
to be a reference point that price
discovery has to be open this is not an
electronic market clicks this will only
become useful as a nascent marketplace
the information is provided in detail
which is why you need to have that what
we call the Red Cross register which we
recording the details going along and
remember this is we're talking
indecently the same would have to apply
in a wider developing reference mark
inflexible there is an argument Jack
your point to have an international
register but all of these are written
down and compared and contrasted so that
the next transaction has the benefit of
price discovery across the entire
database or whatever in kansai of course
it may be all different meg and he did
because at least the locations different
the performance is different the
governor's situations are different will
be arrested if it's lava Bible different
the price doesn't have to agree when
enhance but at least you need to have
making them so that the next class there
are existing system there is a CCD
system which is which some lights on
don't like I'll just put that on Lego
that the two of you who are looking at
the Emily Sullivan and will need to
examine the ccd standards and make up
your own mind where they use to use them
or not and and finally I say this that
it is possible to strip the biodiversity
pinion and this is not a new concept I
mean every bond that's issued which is a
convertible bond effectively a
certificate of the equity option risk at
the time that it is transacted they're
very huge and what would one is actually
insurance but usually they have the
console dollar and the equity coupon or
similar so in the same way you can have
a composite issuance of a red cus
premium ticket and the carbon site goes
to one group of pilots which is
basically the power market and the
biodiversity side goes to another group
of buyers which is those who are more
interested in the species conservation
and biodiversity conservation aspects of
forest conservation so you can strip a
30-minute think of that because part of
your projects is about finding a few
other bodies and also making a degree
kind of assessment of who the buyer is
ha
Oh
it's important to in both your projects
to go down to the geographies and figure
out what you are recommending this part
which provinces because depending on
which species you are focusing on being
tiger or parantha hear the case from
Sumatra we're clearly focusing on York
around the time in proximity areas to
where this is taking place would make
sense because you can see that there is
a concentration and you can see the
potential value of measuring species
count as a way of commiserating as an
indicator of species and other cases it
may not be that ok so you have to go
down to the location please match our
from a standard address the biodiversity
so you should have access to them but
it's important to use them in your
patrols and finally on on the the
Ecuador because of the yes when the IDT
the background you're all familiar with
spell combo through that but I just like
point out that this is some of what has
been committed in the proposal at least
has been proposed by Governor correctly
when it talks about the project and it's
important to see this because this is
what will enable you to have confidence
in framing this as a landscape red cross
product they're talking about our only
needs protection of 39
radiant almost 5 million hectares were
they talking about restoration and
regrowth and management of another 2.3
million hectares in this particular
article said they're talking about the
use of these funds that they collect to
manage both the energy supply side and
supply mix of Ecuador as well as the
demand matrix erection and I think
finally they're also look and that's
important because that is in a sense an
answer to those who argue against
additionality because they would not do
this if they did not have a conscience
it's not correct additionality but this
contingent it's related additional they
will change policy based on the money in
Africa and there is no evidence that
they will change at other times and
finally there is a whole issue of
community because it is an AI with main
traffic ATM and significantly isolated
so there is an element of how to be
frame and address their development and
what benefits they get so yes to me is
actually a good example of how this
whole process might might evolve if it
is a proper landing place technical and
by the way to make it clear Lowell area
we're talking about we've actually an
exclusive so even though the usually
Hawk is apart around it there I Alton
areas and there are mining areas so it's
not as if it's a pristine
stretches out whatever you do have a
situation of these schools and do a
community once again in 12 report cites
so a lot of what I've said today would
be of some interest for those are people
who are working on these projects and I
hope it's peed on something just for the
others as well that's it for today thank
you very much